impeachable and unconscionable that's
the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
t-mine is two hours now hundreds of
thousands of foreigners gaming our
immigration system will begin pouring in
now after they get there though they're
going to be asked you know where they
want to go then they're going to get
their free bus tickets all courtesy of
U.S taxpayers now most of them will not
be screened at all either for diseases
or prior criminal backgrounds sometimes
they'll get a piece of paper telling
them to show up years down the road for
an immigration hearing yeah that's going
to happen
Now understand this and understand it
well
the scenes you're watching tonight are
not happening because of Biden
Administration and confidence
they're happening because this is
exactly what the Democrats want now let
me explain this
liberals and business Elites have been
working toward this for decades and now
they're celebrating what is ultimately
if they really get their way the
destruction of America's middle class
sounds inflammatory hyperbolic Stay With
Me Now why do they want to destroy the
middle class well the far left hates all
those Traditions that the middle class
clings to especially the flag waving
guns religion you get the score and big
business they dislike the middle class
because it's an obstacle to keeping
wages as low as possible remember under
Trump the middle class is better off
their median income was rising and we
had minimal inflation
but a limitless supply of low-wage
workers that's what makes business
happiest and keeps America's middle
class the poorest
the open borders radicals think every
migrant sleeping on the ground tonight
waiting for processing is a future
Democrat voter that's how they see them
the wealthy donors see the migrants as
much needed cheap labor
now it's as simple as that
if those two groups didn't want this to
happen Biden wouldn't have done it
because of what they've done an Untold
number of Americans will not just lose
jobs but lose their lives
for these globalists though it's all
collateral damage they don't care as
long as they get to hold on to Power and
Get Rich that's all that matters
and the justifications that are being
thrown out there all day long in the
cables
to justify Biden's American sabotage
what were they well there's a
predictable as they were unpersuasive
Oh They'll do jobs that Americans won't
do
those folk who are coming across are the
ones who are
helping to
put food on our table without them we're
not able to Ink
oh really because in 1980 when I was in
high school and we didn't have an open
border somehow we managed to have food
in the stores and food on the dining
room table in Glastonbury Connecticut
where I lived
they do it in Australia and in France in
Japan they don't have open borders and
yet somehow they all they almost always
have vegetables and fruit and meat in
their grocery stores hmm
now migrant Farm Workers who come and go
during the seasons well that's an
obvious solution to something we once
did very efficiently right that that
worked but that's not what we're doing
here Democrats want millions and
millions to come here and never leave
and frankly never have any bargaining
power
and now I'll take cabinet secretaries
who most deserve to be impeached for 200
Alex
I want to be very clear our borders are
not open we removed returned and
expelled 1.4 million people last year
ask those 1.4 million people if if they
think the border is open
I bet they do because
I'm right back in
now my orcas is just following orders of
course and the orders aren't coming from
Biden he's barely there
the sheer volume of humanity being
shipped into the interior part of the
United States once they make their way
across the border that's what makes this
scenario tonight different
you've spent a lot of time down there I
mean you've noticed a significant change
from months past
yeah these are by far the biggest
numbers we have ever seen some of the
biggest lines of migrants I have ever
seen and we're also seeing the state of
Texas act differently we have never seen
them physically block migrants from
entering before so a lot of Firsts on
this trip
now I work in class Americans voted for
this
how many African-Americans thought they
were going to get this when they voted
for Biden
but not many why would they vote for
this it would be like voting for your
own destruction
so how is this not a threat to democracy
from those who claim to be the big
guardians of it
Democrats have created dangerous
conditions for the migrants themselves
many of the women have been trafficked
many of the children have disappeared
into modern day slavery
and this will be a guaranteed Financial
Calamity for American cities like New
York and Chicago and for Suburban
schools and hospitals that are already
being stretched to the Limit
but why they're in the game they don't
care they don't really even like you at
this point they just use you and then
they lie to you
we prepared for this moment for almost
two years and our plan will deliver
results our current situation is the
outcome of Congress leaving a broken
outdated immigration system in place for
over two decades despite unanimous
agreement that we desperately need
legislative reform
Liar Liar pantalones on fire
um funny
how was it then that in 2017 and 2018
we didn't have this problem at the
border we didn't have amnesty
we had enforcement and smart policy by
the Trump folks
so when these border crossers turned
themselves in tonight even if they don't
speak English what do they know they
know how to mouth the words credible
fear of persecution which then allows
them to stay in the country it's totally
insane
because it was obvious where this was
all leading the Trump White House
convinced Mexico to make the migrants
wait in Mexico for their petitions to be
considered
well guess what happened then the
Caravan suddenly stopped coming
this should not be allowed to happen how
they're not going to do a version of
title 42 or my title 42 which was tough
if people are sick and have infectious
diseases and lots of other problems we
don't want them being into our country
with the 2 million case backlog in our
immigration courts
How can any president not demand that
Asylum claims be paused until we clear
it all out I know Trump would have done
that
yeah that includes deporting all those
asylees who bailed on their hearings
that figure is in the hundreds of
thousands by the way that just never
showed up
now think about this Democrats impeach
Trump over a phone call with zelenski
a total abuse of the impeachment clause
but if what Biden has created
purposefully tonight in El Paso and Del
Rio and Brownsville if that's not
considered impeachable for what it's
done to the sovereignty of the United
States
I don't know what is
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else